today i'm going to be making music with
my new microkorg and a basic ditto
looper
the guideline i'm giving myself is to
use only these two pieces of gear and to
try to capture the mixture of emotions
i've been feeling lately which can be
maybe described as a combination of a
bit of anxiety
cheeriness and gratitude
long-term optimism but also a bit of
short-term pessimism
and some patience
i really love the simplicity of the
setup which while it has its limitations
it just encourages me to sit down and
start recording something rather than
overthinking things and filtering out a
lot of ideas
here's what i'm starting off with the
rhythm can be broken down as being in
groups of three three
two
three
two
or just considered a phrase in 1316
and i'm using this very basic sine wave
sound that i just rounded off a bit so
that i think it sounds a bit friendlier
[Music]
now with the second layer i'm adding a
bit more harmony to the phrase and i'm
using a sound called plinka box that
comes from this really great set of
patches that i bought for the microkorg
made by my friend cuckoo
here i'm adding faint pad like sounds to
fill in the texture and i'm also using
the volume knob just as a very quick way
to add a little more variety to the
dynamics
here i did something by accident while
trying to create another patch and i
ended up getting this study sound that
i'm going to use as a bass drum
now i'm using the same sound higher in
pitch with a slightly different rhythmic
pattern
and now the same thing even higher in
pitch offset just slightly so that
there's a little bit of a crunch
and now i'm ready to add some chords
which i'll be playing over the loop
instead of recording as a separate layer
so that i have the freedom to go beyond
the number of measures i recorded so far
the sound that i'm using is another
patch by cuckoo and what i really wanted
with this one is to have a sustained
sound because i don't have access to a
pedal with the synthesizer so i'm just
making it as long and drawn out as
possible with a very very soft decay
to go along with the music here is some
footage from my trip across the u.s
while recently moving from the east to
west coast
so enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you